[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today on the show is cat tymph she is a
comedian she's co-host of a show called
Gutfeld on Fox and she's a contributing
editor at Fox News as well as has worked
at Barstool Sports so I feel like you
can't get two different worlds more than
Barstool Sports in box but she wrote a
book called you can't joke about that
which is just like the perfect perfect
launching point to be able to have a
conversation about stuff that we don't
normally get to talk about which is sex
sexuality politics religion death uh
sickness all kinds of stuff that people
just don't always know what to say and
the most important thing is that we have
this opportunity to be able to talk
about stuff like that because it's
through talking about it that we start
to understand it we understand each
other and we're also able to process the
the challenges of those aspects of life
because they for sure have challenges or
big deal enjoy this conversation with
Kat go pick up her book please hit
subscribe and the bell for notifications
and in the comments let me know what you
think and also maybe like what taboo
topics did we miss enjoy
you just got off air do you record for
Fox during the day yeah well I was on a
different show I um we normally record
like I record in like an hour and 15 20
for Gutfeld we record at 6 p.m Eastern
got it how much do you do you write a
bunch of stuff for that or do you have a
lot of producers that write everything
or do you no I I mean all my own stuff I
write all my own stuff and I write some
stuff for Greg too like I usually write
a segment every day I took off writing
when the book first came out like the
first month and now this week I'm back
to writing yeah is that is that part of
like the joy for you yeah it's different
right um just because I'm writing for a
completely different person
but it's really fun and honestly writing
is my favorite thing to do just in
general like the book is what I mean not
so much talking about television writing
but because it is different but I think
I'm a better writer than I am anything
else because I stay true to myself which
can be
interesting because I I'm not a
republican I'm also not a Democrat but I
feel like people who are Democrats or on
the left can be like she works at Fox
and that tells me all I need to know
about her but then there'll be some
viewers obviously a lot of viewers like
me but there'll be some viewers who are
like she's not conservative enough or
she's not conservative on this issue
she's dumb so I just kind of feel like
what's the point of having a platform
just for the sake of having a platform
um so I'm always just gonna say what it
is I actually believe yeah yeah well one
of the things I want to do with you is
like go down the line of all the [__]
that we're not supposed to say because
your book is you can't joke about that
so I thought the most funny way to do
that would be to talk about all the
stuff we're not supposed to so let's
let's take off with politics you know I
thought to myself many times I'm like
why is there Democrat and Republican why
can't it just be that you just listen to
who's running and then then you actually
have to listen instead of just following
along with a color you you listen to
what someone says like would that even
fly like how come it's not like that why
does it have to why do you have to pick
a side
yeah I see I refuse to pick a side but I
think that what the two-party system
does is it kind of allows for corruption
because people are always going to
defend their own side or they're always
going to say okay well what about what
that other person did that on that other
side is worse and that's how the
government on both sides gets away with
so much stuff I mean you can take the
exact same news story and talk to
someone who's Republican and talk to
someone's a Democrat and it's like they
didn't read the same thing or they it
wasn't the same event that they're
talking about and
um I think if you just think in this
binary way you don't really have to
think at all because then all the
thinking is already done for you you
don't have to think where do I stand on
this issue a lot of issues are complex
and there's a lot at play you don't have
to do that you can just be like okay was
it if I'm a republican I can say oh if a
republican did a good thing it's if
Republican did it it's good if a
Democrat did it it's bad
um and so that's actually the enemy of
critical thinking because you don't have
to think which is easier but obviously
results in some pretty stupid outcomes
sometimes yeah I mean you know someone
that I like is um Jordan Peterson and
um I don't know if you've listened to
his work yeah but you know one of the
one of his main points is having
conversations like we have to be able to
talk to each other if you can't talk to
each other then we don't learn and you
really don't want to get you don't
everyone shouldn't agree on everything
because then you don't have growth you
actually have to have disagreements but
then communication and why is it so damn
hard for people to communicate with an
open mind and be able to say either okay
I changed my mind or I'm wrong like why
is that yeah I mean honestly I think
that's one of the main reasons why I
wrote the book
um I talk about you know I had I almost
died in 2020 I had an emergency ostomy
surgery I'm okay now I Had It reversed
but um I was at home recovering and I
talked to my dad and he was like cat
like what have you not been through at
this point and I said well Dad you know
I I was on I was pretty doped up they
give you a lot of oxy if you have a
surgery like that but I was like Dad
like everything you go through you're
automatically building a connection with
everyone else who's been through it too
and I was on oxy but I was right
um but then I thought about it more and
I was like what's the use if we can't
talk about it though
um and so how I that's why I got the
idea for this book I think a lot of
books about comedy and about speech are
like I have the right to say whatever I
want and if you don't like it then like
[__] you and that's all true but I think
that totally ignores the way that it can
also bring us together
um because like you're saying if we
can't fully express ourselves we can't
fully understand each other either and I
also write about how there's so many
different issues where there's these
huge gaps and various demographics of
people between what people say they
believe what they actually believe so
we've kind of created the wrong rules
that not like most of us don't actually
even agree with because we're all so
afraid yeah yeah I mean what's the
solution to that like I don't there's
there's sort of there's a saying and I
don't remember who says whose quote this
is but it's basically that
um instead of trying to fix fix an
existing system just create a new one
so like is it even fixable or is it just
create a new one and start a commune
like I've been talking about for five
years we've probably actually end up in
the same thing because the commune will
get popular it'll be super fun and
everybody will be having a great time
and then all of a sudden there'll be too
many people and then we're like well we
kind of need someone in charge with the
stick you know like yeah I'm in charge
I'm talking and then all of a sudden
you're probably gonna have to have like
a secretary and because there's gonna be
bills and you have to redo roads and
stuff and then all of a sudden we're
going to end up in the same place again
probably but the commune would work for
a while I think I've had the exact same
thought actually really my country would
be called kazstan I've already thought
of that but then I'm like then we'd run
into the same
you know and I'd be like Kazan you do
what you want you take care of you but
then you know again like you said I
probably couldn't handle it all by
myself and I don't want to I don't want
to get into politics because I don't
want to make decisions for other people
I don't understand how
you would want it like people would want
to go into that I just kind of want to
be left alone and leave other people
Alone
um but when it comes to speech stuff you
have to just I mean for me I've always
just decided I'm going to try to lead by
example and that's the reason why I
wrote the book the way I did
um a friend of mine who works here's
name's Guy Benson he has a radio show
here interviewed me and he had an
advanced copy and he said as I was
reading it I was like she she really
just shared that like did she really
just you know make that joke about her
you know her mom dying like her
experience with her mom dying or her
medical emergencies or and it's yes I
did because I want to prove that by
example I want to show that actually yes
you can joke about everything and if I
was gonna write this book and say that
then I had to actually prove that I
meant it because you know the end result
is that I found all of it healing I
found humor healing through all these
traumatic experiences and the other
thing that you need to do and the other
part of living by example is to also be
measured in your response to jokes that
you don't like or to someone saying
something that maybe even offends you
because
I know everybody says like facts don't
care about your feelings and that's true
but also feelings don't care about your
facts sometimes like humans are
emotional creatures I'm a very emotional
person I'm very sensitive but there's a
difference between being sensitive and
expecting the whole world really to
revolve around your own sensitivity
that's just being selfish so I think
that being measured in your criticism if
someone says something you don't like
you can say you know that hurt my
feelings that's different than demanding
that they be fired or something you know
this or that and I think we need to
weigh in tension more someone was just
trying to make a joke that is different
than someone who is trying to be a jerk
right exactly if somebody uses like a
derogatory term as slang versus like
because it's just kind of part of
culture versus something that is it
intentionally meant to make you feel
horrible that's right or how about just
like uh that guy over there and like you
know we're having a crisis moment in
culture of like being able to call
someone girl or a boy right now and like
what if it what if you you don't mean
anything buy it right you're just like
trying to like use a reference it's
really just a guide to like bring
attention oh that person over there like
I don't know I totally agree with you
like I've said this even in
relationships
if something doesn't seem right just
know my intention like my intention is
like I'm not trying to hurt you right
I'm not trying to make you feel bad what
what is the like
I don't know I I think identity politics
is a huge problem right now yeah I do
think it is because I think that also
the people who claim to be the huge
activists for this they don't they're
actually not doing themselves any favors
I mean when it comes to speech
historically I mean from like the Civil
Rights Movement to gay rights movement
to you know Susan B Anthony all that
historically have been very pro-free
speech and pro First Amendment because
they understand that groups that are
fighting for things that might be
marginalized are the ones that need free
speech the most and also let's say like
going back to the trans thing let's say
your main issue the thing that you care
about the most in the world is trans
activism and the last thing you want to
do is treat somebody who for example
does what you did and acts you know
maybe accidentally says something that
hurts somebody's feelings and be like
okay that's it you're a transpho because
then people are going to stop asking
questions and there's not like there's a
very small percentage of people that are
trans so a lot of people have never met
a trans person in their entire life so
if you really want people to understand
your cause and understand people and you
have to be open to having people talk
about it without being afraid to talk
about it that's so true while there's a
healthy amount of awareness that could
be created yes I think there's a dark
side of people wanting to have an excuse
and be to be a victim
I absolutely think that that has to be
the case right because I mean there's
really I mean I I there's this new idea
that like I'm white and someone else is
black then that means that like I
there's nothing that I can say that
could be relatable to that person which
is crazy because I don't know what it's
like to be a black person obviously but
that doesn't mean that as humans that we
would have nothing in common and there's
this idea now even with jokes that if it
draws on you know an experience of a
woman meaning a biological woman who's
born woman is still a woman then that
somehow excludes trans people just
because it's not about you doesn't mean
it excludes you it's just not about you
and it's it does apply to a lot of
people and there should be you know an
outlet because there are unique things
that come with being a biological woman
like you have a period and you know you
worry about different things than
biological men do that's not excluding
anybody because you can also then use
your own voice to share your own
experience and what we've done now is
like you said maybe like even talking
about black artistic people like then
they just don't talk about race at all
or you're like afraid like that's not a
good thing either that's the last thing
people should want and especially when
it comes to jokes when people
are trying to make a joke they're trying
to make people laugh so the intention
there is good and especially with comedy
the only way to know if a joke works or
not is to try it because there's been
times so dangerous it is Contracting as
hell it's you can't tell I mean it's
part of doing it's I mean I I've done
stand up on and off I'm not really doing
it right now kind of doing live shows
that I'm getting back into that are like
half stand up so I'll probably get back
there again because it's hard to quit
once you've done it but you don't know
you can think something's so funny in
your head and then you go on stage and
you're like oh that didn't work and now
the penalty for that is like your whole
career is over and yeah right you don't
cancel because you don't know how it's
going to come off or are people going to
receive it because we're all different
and if we make people too afraid to try
and what's gonna happen is let's say you
don't like this one joke you'll be like
like I was standing there you'll be like
okay that it hurt my feelings and leave
it at that
but you have to keep in mind that you
have to be measured in your response
because you might be making other people
afraid to make other jokes that might be
about subjects that really resonate with
you that you might need during a
difficult time in your life sure I mean
I I agree with you you said a few
minutes ago you said that he you know
humor is is healing and I think a big
aspect of the healing from my
perspective is that you start talking
about it you just get it out there which
is why it's so good that your book is
about talking about stuff you're not
supposed to talk about because no matter
what it is when we don't get it out and
we suppress it that sticks in the body
and becomes disease that becomes
um a projection when someone makes a
comment or does something because you've
got something sticky in there and when
you just joke about it you just you get
it out and you start clearing the air
and we can all we can all laugh and you
can and you it's like a form of
processing it and so like I feel like
the last Mohicans are comedians to being
able to you're like the last line of
defense to being able to say
I'm gonna say just about everything
yeah and I mean if you treat something
as oh so sacred and oh so untouchable
that gives it more power over you you
know and by laughing in its face that's
takes the power away I first started
doing stand-up I mean I talk about this
in my first chapter where I was living
in La things were not going well I was
very broke uh I lived in like this
horrible apartment where I slept on a
yoga mat then I lost the apartment and I
was living with this bartender that I
was like sort of seeing from my
waitressing job but not really and you
know I'd explain to him like we're not
really together because I need to live
here
like 22 years old I didn't know anybody
the only people I knew were like my cat
that's still alive and then my you know
ex-boyfriend who had broken up with me
and so I started getting on stage and
telling jokes about this stuff and it
wasn't that this stuff was funny right
but I was able to poke fun at it which
gave me I felt totally powerless the
rest of the time that was the one time
like I felt like I had some power and
then hearing other people laugh was my
only means of connection through that
time so I mean that's just kind of How
It's been throughout my entire life
because
I think the what it's get what can make
something worse if you're going through
it and it's hard is when people are
weird around you if they know like
you're going through something bad like
after my mom died people are like scared
to talk to me I'm like that's not
helping if we like look at this
comedians next to politicians or sorry
not politicians news people that's what
I mean but if we use Politics as the
platform it's like comedians can joke
about it so you're in this really cool
spot where you're on the news
essentially
but you're a comedian and you're able to
joke about stuff so why I mean where
does it fall with people in news being
able to have an opinion I mean obviously
the Tucker Carlson stuff happened and I
mean both Fox and CNN
um getting having people get fired so
what what why it where do you see there
being a pathway for people in the news
to be able to just be honest it doesn't
and it doesn't have to follow follow a
color or uh or um
uh a belief system based on the channel
that you're on like can we ever get
there
it's tough and I I have absolutely no
idea what happened with the Tucker thing
which is why it's like my book came out
the same week and everybody's like well
I really don't know but just overall I
think that I can understand
sometimes how people can get tempted to
be like okay I have this audience and
they love me and also okay I'm making
money because this audience loves me so
what how what if I say this thing that
my audience is not gonna like but I
believe it to be true
for me I've just I've LED with [__] it
and like every single time and I don't
care I mean I work at Fox but like I'm
I'm agnostic I'm not Republican
um you know it's like but I'm also you
know like I'm pro-second Amendment so I
I'm all over the place so it would be
issues wherever
um but I'm also like you know I'm like
for the legalization of drugs and I'm
for the legalization of sex work so I'm
not like I don't really fit into a box
so I know that no matter where I went
there'd be issues but I do believe
people are Unique Individuals and I feel
like nobody can really fit into a box
perfectly right and I I saw Elon Musk
got a bunch of [__] for what he said
about you know George Soros which I
don't really care that much about what
he said so much as what he said after
which he said well if I lose money for
saying what I think then so be it now he
has a lot of money so right
it's okay with losing Millions yeah
exactly but it's just crazy how
remarkable it was to see somebody say
that like I'm telling you I don't care
and it would be better if more people
were like that because I also think
social media has something to do with it
like you could be on TV back in the day
and people could hate you and you
wouldn't really know it's like now I
know every single person what like what
all these people think about my body
what they think about my marriage what
they think about my face it's like I
know I have a big forehead like but they
can get into you like and they're like I
I liked you and then you said that about
this it's like blocking you I'm done
never again and I used to not look at it
and I've kind of Fallen back into
looking at it and it's really toxic it's
really toxic for your your mind body and
soul to look at it yeah but it's also
impossible not to and I think that that
can really lead to it too because you
you worry like I'm gonna upset this mob
but then you also realize
who are those people
you know no right some of them are many
of them are yeah they're [__] I just
picture them fat in their parents
basement with a bag of Cheetos and a
Mountain Dew and they're like
miserable AF that's what I picture when
people are nasty I'm like I feel bad for
them yeah I know it's like I've I've
watched TV for you know not to brag for
many decades now I've been watching TV
and I've seen people on that I'm like oh
I don't really like that person or what
they have to say I've never been like
okay better let them know I'm gonna get
out Mike I'm gonna go tell them and then
while I'm at it I'm gonna say that
they're ugly and they're this or that
like I don't so you have to you know but
it can feel overwhelming if you look at
all these you know but it's like that's
just small percentage of the population
and what percentage is that and like
those aren't normal people that I would
really want in my corner anyway just
like when you look at social media and
you see like super perfect hot women and
you're like God you feel so bad about
yourself because everybody everybody's
so beautiful
and I like I've said this to my friends
before but I think it's myself too I'm
like
you know I walk around in life
and I see almost no women that look like
that none right when I do my own life
beta test on that I'm like yeah yeah
actually yeah it's [__] there's
there there there's like none of them
there is almost none of them which means
that there's either almost there's
almost none of them and they're fake
because they just use all of the all of
the apps which that's a good point yeah
it's like the exact same thing in the
reverse because yeah it's like there's
apps that can give you like a whole
entirely different face it is tough
though and I think that we really are
in a tough spot where people are so
afraid to speak and people everything is
so polarized I like I feel like if I
have this platform I just owe it to and
it's like I'm not religious so I don't I
don't know what I owe it to but I
wouldn't feel right about so if I've
gotten [__] for things I've said before
but and it could be tough but I don't
know how I would deal with it if I knew
the [__] I was getting was for something
I didn't even believe
yeah that I just wanted to like make
money off of or make people happy and
fit in with the brand I could that I
couldn't deal with at least I can say
well I said what I felt and I always
know that I was true to myself you were
saying like you're confused you know why
you're doing it I'm gonna bet it's
because it's changed your life it has
you know like we tend to advocate for
anything that's like we're super sold on
it's like
man I had tried that low carb diet it
really worked and you just want to tell
everyone or like hey I started CrossFit
and it was just the best thing I ever
did and you feel like you have to tell
everyone or or you you know you get
things off your chest by joking and
you're like I want to tell everyone
because this is a this is a cure
yeah it really honestly it really has
been for me I mean over and over again
in my life I mean even when when my mom
died I wasn't able to talk about it the
way that I am now I had a really hard
time talking about it because I mean I
just turned 26 I had just gotten the job
at Fox like a few months right after she
died
I felt so awkward because people would
be like I
I'm like yeah like I know like me too
but
Mother's Day the first one was tough and
then the second one I had just gotten a
little more comfortable with it and so I
reposted this to my Instagram but back
in 2016 I posted a picture of my laundry
basket a bottle of tide and I just wrote
mom's dad gonna do some laundry and I
like laughed about it and I went out you
know because I'm like
that's how ugly it is and that's how
great you know it's like it's just
another day for me but people were
telling me like you shouldn't say that
that's disrespectful and I'm like to who
you never met her so probably this is
harder for me than you and then I think
that just shows when we treat like
subjects as sacred just because we're
supposed to we actually end up hurting
people yeah and the same people that
they're supposed to protect like in that
situation me yeah yeah what do you wish
people would have said to you
I wish they would say that sucks or ask
me a question about her or if there's
someone who I knew to
like tell me a story about her when
someone gets like about it I just say
it's okay you didn't kill her and then
like it lifts lightens it up a bit and
then they I feel like they can talk to
me like a normal person again well you
you disarm the situation yeah right yeah
which that's what it does it is it is
probably a little easier when it's a
complicated concept for someone to make
a joke but you know it doesn't do any
good to not bring it up what are some
other things that you feel like you
wanted to bring to light that people
have such a hard time talking about
my chapter five which is called [__] bag
so I had an emergency ostomy surgery
during in 2020
um it was like a fluke thing
um it was an emergency surgery I had the
bag and as I was getting wheeled into
surgery I was like oh my God what am I
gonna tell people like I almost died and
I was like this is so gross people are
gonna think I'm weird what do I do of
all the traumas I could have had why is
this trauma so Niche you know
yeah and I didn't tell anybody I mean I
came back to work and I had the bag for
five weeks and I just was on air with
this poop tube and I didn't tell anyone
like where'd you put it in the front
right here it's like right it's it's
like right below your rib cage like your
intestine comes out so I would have to
just be very strategic about what I wore
um
what you could hide it it could hide it
yeah I could hide it but it wasn't just
like the American people couldn't no but
like people at work couldn't see it they
couldn't see it I was I wore like really
baggy stuff like Greg knew but most
people didn't know because I was like I
don't want to be weird and then the
second surgery
I had complications where I won't get
like super graphic but like a staple was
loose and it was all like the blood was
all coming out of my ass that's like the
most polite way I can say it diapers and
I write about in detail in my book and
they told me I needed a transfusion and
that day that they did that was on
January 6th which is like that's funny
you know because I'm like my friend
there who's he was my flower girl in my
wedding a little gay gymnast boys my
best friend you know he's there he's
like when everyone asks you where you
were like you'll be able to tell them
you were doing this is what was going on
I'm like this is funny but I still
people were like so I was gone for two
weeks and I didn't know what to tell
people because I still was like this is
so weird I don't know what to say it's
like so gross and then I was like okay
you know uh my uncle I told the plot of
The Lion King as in a statement without
saying I didn't know what to do and then
finally when this book came out or as I
was writing this book I was just curious
and I thought more about how like people
have died with cancer that we didn't
know they had like Norm Macdonald like
Chadwick Boseman in and it's like oh wow
they didn't want to be treated where is
what they said and then I Googled the
words on a hunch cancer and then how to
tell people I have cancer and how to
tell people that people I have cancer
had way more results
so
I all this research also backs up that
talking about it in a humorous way when
you're terminally ill is actually ranked
higher in terms of being more helpful
than solemnity and even actually more
helpful than physical medication pain
relief totally yeah that last one was
energy study but yeah it's crazy I'm a
little bit of a hippie hippie spiritual
Guru and uh or or like into it um yeah
and uh like I believe in energy a lot
and so like just the the positive energy
and frequency of laughing is so
beneficial to the body that you know I
it does not Shock me that there are
stats out there that humor
um can be even more beneficial than
medicine yeah and making and they say it
makes people feel better so I think
that's another one because people like
oh but you don't mean illness I'm like
no I do like you don't mean death I'm
like no I mean I yes I do and
um it's been really healing the first
time I ever talked about the back I
publicly was when the book came out so a
lot of people at work like realize they
were on TV with me during that time and
they had no idea but it is really
healing and that's my last chapter I
write about how comedy is actually a
sort of religion for me because it has a
lot of the same healing properties as
you know physically but also emotionally
as religion does and the way it can add
meaning to experiences because and I'm
writing the book about all these things
that almost destroyed me and I was able
to actually create from those things
obviously it doesn't offer eternal life
but
it has a lot of the other same
properties I know I'm still hoping to
figure out what what happens with that
one but I think it needs the Forgiveness
right most religions have a pathway to
forgiveness
and
um I was Catholic for a long time so I
know enough about the Bible and
Christianity and Catholicism and so
Leviticus is like the least chill book
in the Bible or one of the least chill
and even that one is like an eye for an
eye and what we do now with comedy and
joke is actually even worse than
Leviticus because if you ask somebody I
don't care how into this you know
identity politics they are and you said
name a few of the worst things that ever
happened to you nobody would actually
say it was hearing a joke that I didn't
like but some people might say it was
telling the wrong joke
so if we're being less chill than
Leviticus I think that we really need to
fix it oh my God yeah I mean we would uh
we would be missing a huge uh taboo
topic if we didn't talk about religion a
little bit yeah
um so you were a Catholic right is that
is that correct I was so Catholic I was
an altar server I did bread and water
fasts as a child for the souls and
Purgatory it's like child abuse dude my
mom was so Catholic it's crazy like she
would put like Benedict Metals over all
the I write about this in this over the
doors and like to keep the devil out so
I grew up being like scared of the devil
but I also thought I had this like
benevolent being looking out for me so
maybe that's why like I've been pretty
needy in a lot of my relationships until
I got a lot of therapy because like
nobody can be God but
um I I fell away from that for several
reasons I mean I was so Catholic I
thought I was going like I would go to
confession and tell the priests
everything like that I was doing that
was bad even if it like when I got older
and the sins were like you know weirder
things to talk to a strange old man
about
and I yeah I truly thought I was going
to hell and I fell away from it for a
few reasons partially because I don't
agree with a lot of the stuff but like I
don't feel like if you masturbate and I
write about this in the book and you
like crash your car on the way to
confession that you should go to hell
forever like I think that's a little
it's like not cool and I also just make
a lot of sense no it doesn't and I also
feel like and I do actually I have a lot
of my mom's family that is very Catholic
and they've had a heart as I talk openly
about this and they have a hard time
being like they think of going to hell
because I'm not Catholic anymore and
they will really go in on me and I'm
like but you love me you're capable of
loving me even though I'm not so like
wouldn't God be capable of loving me
um so I it's religion is definitely a
taboo one especially
you know for me to talk about and it's
just you have to because I kind of like
suffer I thought it was so bad for a
long time well I mean that right there
is one reason to be suspicious if
something makes you feel so bad all the
time how can it be that good when we're
literally just finishing a topic about
laughter is healing it's like guilt and
shame are literally the lowest frequency
energies that you can emit I was dating
this guy and he was Christian I made
some funny comment about it was like
some it was like the Jim Carrey moment
when he was on the red carpet and
started talking about tetrahedrons and
oh we're just dancing so I was repeating
that and then he was like oh we're gonna
get her to talk to the priest and
straighten her out or talk to the pastor
and straighten her out talking about me
and I looked and if looks could kill I
was a newsy for sure
I was so when I talked to him I was like
so you're telling me that because it
actually happened
um so I'm like so you're telling me that
if there's like a kid in another country
that he's never read the Bible or heard
of it or doesn't have any idea but
they're like a really good kid and they
die they're going to hell because unless
you believe in the story that's the only
way you get to go to heaven and he's
like well I'm just here to talk about
the Bible if you have any questions
about the Bible I can answer I'm like um
anything else and it's like
so many wars exist still because of
religion like yes I mean why is it why
is religion so divisive it is and it's
it's interesting because I mean like
I've I would love to you know I would
love to be religious in some way someday
just because I would love to think that
I'm more than just like an aging bag of
like bones and meat held together by a
skin sack but I that's the kind of the
issue for me too right I just I can't
make myself believe it and I hate when
people act like that's also a decision
of mine like you don't why don't you
believe it just believe it and it's like
that doesn't work that way for me and
also you know that's what I mean when I
say everyone has their sacred cows right
because there's a lot of people who walk
around like I'm not offendable I'm not
offended by everybody these these woke
[__] are ruining everything but if I
make a joke about you know Christianity
then they lose it and I'm like right
talking about everything I do mean
everything you know I including religion
and I I can say like the mildest things
sometimes about religion and people like
so I'm like no but I can and I remember
like the passive aggressive way like oh
bless her I'll pray for you yeah you're
saying I'm horrible yeah I know it's
like I don't mind if people say I'll
pray for you and they just like trying
to be nice people like oh I'll pray for
her like she's a bad girl
and it's like no like come on and I just
and it's it's also I don't like I don't
treat you that way you know I'm not like
you believe in God and therefore I don't
like you or I don't want to hear what
you have to say or you're this religion
and I don't want to hear what you have
to say and I just want to be have the
same respect well there's like a a
little like psychological perspective
that
um the things that we deny we judge so
like for me as an example like I deny
myself lazy time like I tend to not be
someone to sit around and do nothing so
then when I see someone lazy
what I call Lazy I judge them right so
think about all the things that they
that like especially within religion
people deny right like it's kind of like
a the institution itself is built around
uh regiments and doing certain things
and not doing other things and so
there's so many areas to deny yourself
hence judge others
yeah that's true I mean I was doing this
bread and water fast in the fourth grade
like by myself like I wanted to do it
like I wasn't forced to do it but I was
like so into it and it's just crazy for
me to think about it now because I used
to feel bad for other people like that
weren't religious I was like so what
happened what switched yeah I just I I
just I didn't believe it I just I just
couldn't believe it I think a lot of it
was
like certain sexual things being like
great any sexual things not certain
sexual things like all sexual things
being grave sins right and just being
like why and like I can that really be
true and if this person is a great
person but they have sex before they're
married they're gonna go to Eternal
damnation and like why so that honestly
was what it was because I saw that as
being completely harmless you know I saw
that as being very much a personal
decision that you can make for yourself
and that was really what it what it was
for me yeah great we're on to the next
topic sex I love it yeah
um I uh I read this book called The
Magdalene manuscript these this couple
that wrote a book one of them did a
channeling transmission from Mary
Magdalene about the life that she lived
and that's the first section of the book
and Mary Magdalene is talking about sex
being a way to
um like increase she had sex with Jesus
and that they were doing it
um to she was also helping him
strengthen his car body which is the
energetic field around you and it was
preparing him for the things that he had
to do and gave him the strength to get
through them
um but it was talking about just like
how you can use it for manifesting and
you can use it to it there's just like
so many things about sex that are really
really like powerful but it's been like
torn from everyone
to even talk about it let alone learn
about it or you know uh get better at
being able to use it as a tool other
than just to get off like right I mean
and that's like you know one of those
taboo things that we're not supposed to
talk about I almost felt bad like
posting that I read a book called The
Magdalene manuscript and it said it was
like it's tight like sex is in it it's a
Sex Magic Sex Magic and whatever and the
cult of ice a cult of Horus and
um yeah but I mean sex is like one of
those things that about whatever I mean
animals do it yeah I I know and it's
it's it's first I don't know why it's so
taboo and I mean for me it was like
growing up it was like no like it was
like really and I obviously don't think
that way anymore and I talk way more
openly about it now and I I it's just
like the shame is so harmful except like
there is also this Resurgence of some
people being like if you're a woman and
you have sex X and like you have set you
have like too many partners whatever
that even means and then like no you're
damaged like no one's ever gonna want
you and no one will tell these women the
truth about and it's like that's not the
truth like that's not the truth if
you're a woman who's a lot of partners
then you just you just did that you know
I I think it's it's so harmful it's so
harmful to because I think really what
can be a like maybe if anything a turn
off to people could be like if you hate
yourself if you're really insecure if
you do things that don't feel right to
you and then you or you do things that
do feel right to you and then you judge
yourself for it anyway I think that's
people really need to be able to be more
open about it and own it because a lot
of people too who are judgmental about
stuff like that have like weird freaky
skeletons in their closet a lot of the
time too
well they're denying themselves you know
yeah exactly I've never I'm gonna be
thinking about that now like all the
time I've never heard about like just
think about something that you you judge
in other people
yeah
my because I think laziness is mine too
honestly and do you deny yourself the
ability to really like chill out and do
nothing I have a meltdown I book my
schedule like non-stop because if I'm by
myself and I'm not doing anything I'm
like
I'm losing time I'm losing money like
what am I doing something I I'm wasting
I'm wasting time I yeah
yeah if it's not working just to be work
or like a really fulfilling you know
emotional social some sort of thing like
you know whether it's friends or with my
husband whatever it is if it's not like
if I'm just sitting on the couch I'm
like
I I lose it
yeah so I think that's probably a big
one for me yeah it's an interesting
psychological perspective but it works
for everyone so now you know with your
husband whatever he he is denying
himself he judges the most in you so I
know I know it first ask them what he um
what he what he's judgmental about in
people
I will and then you can then you know
what he's denying and then you can just
slip it in there after and be like well
now I know this about you is this true
and he'll be like oh that's really good
I'm definitely gonna do that as soon as
I get home
oh my God is marriage great you got
married a couple years ago right yeah
it's great and write about this in the
book I did a little like a lot of losers
I dated like I mean I loved a loser and
I think it was because I maybe wasn't
ready and also because if they were a
loser they couldn't really hurt me I
think that was probably part of it like
if a loser doesn't want anything to do
with me then like whatever I can tell
myself he's a loser
um I dated like a lot of you know
musicians artists people like that
and then he's like
a white guy who's from Westchester who
works in finance and like fought in
Afghanistan he's like an investment
banker like a good guy and I thought he
was like I was like he's boring he has a
good job but on the first date I wasn't
really my sister convinced me to go out
with him
and then I was like okay maybe I was
like dating a lot of other people and I
was happy with that I was like dating
around I was like I don't need a
boyfriend I really truly didn't care I
know that they tell you that you do but
I didn't and uh then the second date my
sister was like just go with him one
more time after I canceled two more
dates on him he showed up and he was
like yeah he shut up he was wearing like
a sweatshirt and like he hadn't shaved
and I was like he's hot and then we
actually never spend another night apart
we moved in together at like four months
really yeah damn because dates usually
get like I realize like if you get past
the third one it's like the third one
you either never see him again or it's
on yeah and he's yeah it was on I mean
he's again he's like my polar opposite
and
he's just so like cool I mean he's so
patient I mean he he's
to be you know the husband of somebody
who does what I do it takes somebody
who's really strong and certain in
themselves like for example in my live
shows I a lot my on my live show in
Chicago I was talking about or I
mentioned how he still had sex with me
when I had my [__] bag on and I'm saying
this while he's sitting next to my dad
you know what I mean like so it's like I
write in the book and I'm like here's a
copy for your mom she's gonna know you
banged me with the bag on like he has to
be very he never ever ever is like don't
I wouldn't share that or this or that
he's like you do you he's like this
works for you to do you I'm
I have no right nor would it even be
smart of me to think that I know what
you're doing you knew what you're doing
and so he's very secure and cooling
himself which if I always thought like a
guy like that with that kind of resume
couldn't be like chill
yeah wow they say that there's like 13
of the population is securely attached
versus the rest of the people are either
anxious attached or avoidant yeah and
I'm like 13 really I don't even believe
that like I'm not even like I'm anxious
but I I'm aware I think so I'm like what
I'm doing right now is wrong and I need
to stop and I need to apologize I'm
really self-aware I think a lot of
people are not self-aware yeah I feel
like you are really good at um doing
things that make you uncomfortable yeah
I do I force myself to yeah where does
that come from
you know I think because my biggest fear
is to have not accomplished some things
I didn't try or because I was too afraid
to put myself out there and also because
I have failed
so many times and if you do stand up and
you just like have a hot bomb you know I
said I'm obviously most of my sets
weren't bombs or I wouldn't have kept
doing it but uh you know it's like okay
that's the worst that can happen and you
kind of move on I think it's way worse
to never try and that doesn't mean it
doesn't hurt but I I always I mean I
used to do these man on the street
videos I worked at bar stool and I did
man on the street videos that in like
some crazy locations like I went to a
Juggalo convention in the middle of
Thornville Ohio and it was a much
smaller operation at the time it was
just me and like some this guy Paul uh
this his name's Gaz he's like actually
one of the shareholders he just he was
the camera guy he had like these salmon
colored shorts on and it was like people
it was like a scary environment but it's
like you have the scariest thing to me
is to not be scared because then you
don't grow and then you never will know
what could have been I hope you're right
about that in the book did you write
about that too I do yeah I do I write
about that in the book about how safe
spaces aren't real
um anyway because every different person
is gonna have a different idea of what
that is you know
um one person let's say somebody people
were someone was raped someone might
have their safe space be somewhere that
that's not gonna be brought up another
person their safe space who was also
right might be to be able to make jokes
about it and talk about it so it's not
real and there's also research that I
write about my book that shows that you
know that there's these positive
feelings and growth that can come from
feeling uncomfortable that can only come
from feeling uncomfortable so you don't
just feel good but you feel good in a
way that only being uncomfortable can do
for you
so I mean if I think back at all these
times in my life that were the most
meaningful Milestones I mean like
they were all a lot of them were really
scary things and it didn't even have to
be trauma but even doing stand-up comedy
is really scary or you know deciding
okay I'm going to I can't afford grad
school so I'm not going to take out a
loan I'm going to stay here in LA and
you know try to do internship that was
scary all of the things that have been
the most pivotal moments of my life were
the scariest ones and um that doesn't
mean I'm not freaking out because I am
anxious and I do freak out the entire
time but I just say let's [__] go and
I do it anyway let's [__] go
everything yeah write this [__] down
let's [__] yeah and and just like do
the [__] that scares you right like I
totally agree with you what was the
environment at Barstool like was it uh
how many years ago were you at bar stool
I was there like 2016 like 20 yeah it
was a totally different like yeah
different office like Dave was there and
right it was a different office I had a
podcast and I would and I would be in
like once a week oftentimes when like
nobody was there yeah but I mostly did
like these videos in other locations
like I went to Cancun spring break and
asked people political questions that
was a really funny one and like the
audio quality the video is so good it's
so funny these kids are insane like
they're wild but like the audio quality
is shitty because it was such a smaller
operation when I was there but I went
back recently to do some of their shows
just because my book's out and stuff but
it's funny because I was there like way
back before they were anything but
they're cool like I I like you know I I
like doing their stuff yeah I've been
there I went there a couple times for a
couple of different interviews and you
always it's it's like it just seems
world's different than going to work for
Fox News like you know what I mean like
it's just you know we talked about
crystals and you know all kinds of like
weird [__]
um and we weren't you know like they
just totally pushed the envelope and you
know news platforms don't so did you do
you like do you like being at Fox do you
like what is what what's the biggest pro
and con of let's say like Barstool and
then Fox
see I think that saying that I work at
Fox is also almost misleading because of
the show that I do
um because it got failed we do talk
about all kinds of weird stuff
um I it is more like comedy focused
um Barstool was super fun and obviously
like you have more leeway so like that's
a pro but I also have found that I've
had a lot of leeway at cuff Feld and as
my book has come out and I've been able
to do these interviews I have said a lot
of things and I've not had a single
phone call about how I shouldn't have
said anything so I think that that's
pretty awesome
um I mean I think probably the biggest
negative is just like the people think
Fox is a monolith and it's not like I've
I've said this before but it's also true
if I've been at a party somewhere and
people ask me what I do and they don't
know who I am I've just said like porn
I'm like I do porn and people like
that's cool because it's less
controversial than saying that you work
at 5 Fox News that's so funny that's so
true yeah they're like oh that's cool
that's cool and it's like it's like you
know if you'll ever see these people
again I'm really truly like girl on girl
stuff yeah and I'm like yeah thanks what
are you into yeah I'm like I'll be like
yeah like I live in Puerto Rico the
attack they don't have to deal with the
taxes like because it's like if I tell
people like a fox they're like and I'm
like they think that that tells them
everything there is to know about me
when actually
there's people here who believe all
kinds of different things I mean even
like one of my best friends here who
married my husband and I as Kennedy who
was you know an MTV VJ in the 90s who
has a show on Fox Business and like
she's not what you would typically think
of as a fox person our show's not what
you typically think of as a fox show and
even though a lot of the people around
me are certainly I mean on Gutfeld he's
he's not like he's not religious either
he's not really super like socially
liberal or he's not really super
socially conservative I'm more so even
more social liberal because I'm very
socially liberal but I'm still me you
know like even if I'm surrounded by
people that might not agree with me that
I'm still me so I still have this
platform you touched on it a little bit
early on about reading comments but I
mean for a comedian man I mean you guys
are on the hot seat for sure because you
talk about the most controversial stuff
so was there an acclimation to that or
is is it just is it within you to say
[__] it it is also gottfeld gave me some
advice which is has proven to be true
which is that it's never going to be the
thing you think it is which has been the
case
um my biggest issue that I write about I
go do a deep dive into this and um I
forget I think maybe it's the second
chapter third chapter I don't know but
the biggest one of the biggest
controversies was I made a joke about
how difficult it is to give a cat like a
feral cat medication because they have
claws and it was during a segment about
Jimmy Kimmel saying that he was like
taking some shows off this is in 2020
and I did not realize that he had a son
with a heart problem I did not realize
that I remember reading the article and
saying that he said everyone in his
family was healthy so I had that in my
head but I was like oh it's way harder
like I was getting my cat heart medicine
it's harder to give a cat medicine
because they have claws like kids don't
have claws like making what I thought
would be a funny relatable joke to
people who are also childless about how
like for some reason kids are the Casual
excuse for anything whatever we were
live and we never do the show live and
we actually haven't done a lot since
then because Greg was like I would like
to just remind you that he has and I was
like I just died inside it actually made
it on the watch people die inside Reddit
page like it was bad and I I obviously
was like sorry I like blurted something
out the next time I had a chance to talk
I was like I'm so like I'm so sorry I
would never I obviously don't think it's
you know obviously don't think it's more
difficult to have a sick cat than a sick
child like a sick right you know but I
was like if anybody took it that way it
was not my intention blah blah blah
everything was fine right everything was
fine the next day I'm ironically at the
vet with my cat and somebody had posted
just the clip being like here she is
making fun of the kid because he's a
heart disease everybody was like I I had
trouble getting out of bed it went on
for days like his sister told me to [__]
off and die people were like kill
yourself like it was really bad and it's
like I if I going back to my talking
about earlier if I would have actually
been like you know what [__] kids with
heart problems then I would have
deserved all that but it was an accident
I was talking about my cat I didn't even
like there was no kid in the
conversation as far as I know and um I
thought I had no idea that that was
going to be that so it's like I and then
that resurface unread it again it
happened again so I'm always like I
can't go into every show being like is
this gonna get me in trouble because I
won't be able to do my job A and B it's
never the stuff that I think it's gonna
be right like look at the three minutes
of worth of interview versus the 13
seconds that is out there
um so what's the magic to being able to
talk about
taboo off limits topics like how do you
make a joke like how could you how do
you make a joke about that you know how
do we how do we formulate a joke about
sex or politics or religion or death
like what is the magic formula there is
no magic formula that's the issue is is
um so I talk about how comedians need to
have the right to swing and miss and
like that story has still a big example
of a really big mess it was a very big
mess
um but there's also you know I think
it's just
you have to talk about it because
otherwise you're making it really sacred
and giving it more power and making it
even more scary than it already is
I have found it to be helpful I've seen
other people find it helpful and if the
biggest worry is that people are gonna
get mad at you for trying to heal your
own pain or the pain of other people
then that's the wrong way to look at it
and you have to just remember that
um and also you need to also remember
that you like the jokes don't have to be
funny necessarily for me it's my job I'm
supposed you know I but I'm just
thinking about my husband like he's not
funny and like thank God like he makes
me laugh but he's not like a funny guy
which thank God because I'm the funny
guy and it works better that way but um
he has been able to you know if I I was
struggling with certain things and that
in the pandemic just I I don't do well
like we were talking about when I don't
have things to do and I have places to
go I was like melting down and he was
making fun of me about it in a funny
like like in a light-hearted way and it
wasn't really good but it made me laugh
I was like oh this is something I can
laugh at sure so it disarms things and
the worst thing that could happen is
that it won't and people might get a
little upset but you have to just not
care because what's at stake here is to
have everybody lose the ability to heal
in that way yeah yeah so what is what's
your perspective on this whole cancel
culture right now of being
on the hot seat at all times for
offending someone I mean you can't call
someone he or she anymore without
possibly offending someone it's it's
pathetic because and I really do think
that's what it is I think
I mean there's so much discussion about
old tweets right like there was I wrote
about this in my book too like athletes
like college athletes or whatever they
get signed and they find back that like
oh like you know years ago they said
something offensive when they were like
you know 15 or 17 or whatever like we
all did and there's all this
conversation about how it wasn't okay
for them to say this thing before they
had a fully formed brain or even close
to it and no conversation about
who went and looked for those and why
did they look for those and my suspicion
is because maybe they are not where they
want to be in their life and it's like
okay maybe I can take down this person
but that doesn't make you any more
successful yourself really and I also
think social media removes Humanity in a
lot of ways
um it's so easy to pile on you just you
could just quote tweet and be like this
or wow or whatever and then like you're
like see I'm one of the good ones not
like that bad one you don't have to
actually face that person like hit
retweet or repost or yeah and you'd have
to face that person who's like I lost my
job like I lost my whole life you don't
have to worry about that and also social
media I there's research in my book that
shows that Twitter Facebook these posts
do better when they have the Moral
grandstanding Moral emotional language
the engagement's higher on those posts
which is very different than real life
if you think about it because if you had
a friend like that that was just
preaching non-stop in a condescending
way all the time you wouldn't invite
that person over anymore you stop
hanging out with that person but on
social media that's rewarded so I think
that that's a huge part of the issue
what do you think the transformation
with those platforms is going to be
because it does seem like they're they
get controlled a lot they get
um uh you know their the posts get
removed I mean I had one picture it was
like a carousel like 10 photos back in
Indiana last summer and in one of the
photos my sister has four kids now one
of her kids was two and we were at a
like a a lake in a river in Indiana and
she was naked she's two and we're in the
water and they took it down because like
in the far distance there was a naked
butt of a two-year-old yeah I mean
there's just so much censorship and also
you know I mean there's Bots too there
really is like fake stuff and so and
it's also you know people are
recognizing the mental health aspect of
social media and what it does I mean
some of these platforms already have
built-in filters because they're just
trying to keep up like you don't even
know what you look like anymore
um exactly so what is the transition
like what's gonna happen with it do you
think I think it gets worse
I mean unfortunately it's worse before
if it gets figured out doesn't it yeah I
mean I don't know especially because
obviously I got to grow up without
social media right like there's this
whole generation of people that didn't
there's a whole generation of people who
like they have Instagram when they're
like eight years old they're not
supposed to but they do totally you know
it's crazy like what are the impacts of
that gonna be and I mean with Twitter I
mean like that's been it's been an
interesting shake up with you know Elon
Musk buying I even wrote in my book I
was like
I have no idea because he bought it like
as I was in the editing process and I
was like I have no idea what he's gonna
do by the time
that there was a lot of uh there was a
lot of ups and downs to that yeah
exactly I'm like by the time this book
comes out I have no idea
but I really think
I think that more speech is better as
long as the speech is well intentioned
and that's kind of where I stand with
that for sure I think being aware of
these things of some of the things like
that I do talk about in The Book of the
ways in which it's not real life and the
ways in which it's different from real
life
are going to be really crucial because
it can really warp your mind in a lot of
different ways yeah maybe if we did
maybe if you totally got rid of like
retweet and repost and re-everything
think about how much less traffic there
would be if everyone had to write their
own things yeah that's true I mean
there's there's so many different things
right I mean and there's all these
different algorithms and then what are
they and it's I mean I I hate that I
spend so much time on it but I do but
they do a good job of making it like
crack they do like what the crack was
like I bet it'd be like that exactly
yeah I like the Instagram reels I'll be
going through it I'm like Oh my like
I've been doing this for an hour right
totally so bad I mean I'll stop at a
stoplight and I will fill my time at the
stoplight with it yeah it's really bad
and I think that it's probably gonna get
I mean we all need to like go touch
grass you know what I mean for sure like
all of us need to and and I think that
just more education about it is going to
be what the solution is because I feel
like it's also new especially when we
talk about younger people yeah God I
love that well cat thanks for writing a
book about being able to talk about the
things that our people are scared to
talk about because it's super healthy
and super healing so congrats on having
a super successful book already and um
hopefully it's just one of those things
that keeps going thank you so much for
having me you're super cool thanks how
are you this is really fun I I love your
perspectives and
um it's probably why you're so popular
thank you thanks everybody for listening
to the pretty intense podcast today I
hope you enjoyed it if you like what you
heard today and you want to hear more
please click on the Subscribe button